[Music]
toy story was visionary inside out was a
true original and wreck-it Ralph was
still pretty good
but now the secret world under our own
premise ends up like Taco Bell through a
human centipede in the emoji movie
experience a film that only comes around
when a studio exec has custody of the
kids for a weekend where the underlying
IP is the top priority
while story plot character humor and
tone come tight for dead last in a film
that may not be the worst one ever made
but it is the worst example of Hollywood
farting out 80 minutes of cynical
branded advertising and pretending it's
a movie to honest here's a poop joke you
might be making too much stink out of
all this you know emojis those little
pictures morons use instead of words did
you ever wonder if they were alive no
how about with their day job is like no
their love life never will too bad
because you're going inside the plant
animated world of your phone whether you
like it or not full of three-dimensional
representations of two-dimensional text
icons with one dimension to their
personalities and zero depth to any of
this are you finished
me G the Mamo G voiced by humanity's own
Matt TJ Miller he needs to believe in
himself get the girl
save the world and probably some other
generic protagonist goals you'll miss
while you nap to the second act watch
him and the carpool karaoke guy travel
from app to app to show off all the
cross-promotion sony was able to sell
but because internet culture moves
faster than it takes to animate a movie
all the apps are outdated candy crush
all the slang is embarrassing hashtag
blessed NBD dude Oh shade and all the
emojis have about six months of
relevance left until they're replaced by
apples horrifying human emoji hybrids
we've got a chicken
[Music]
okay think of the laziest joke you can
think of in the nosebleeds I'm standing
right here know even lazier what kind of
business
monkey business now dumb it down to the
point where it barely makes sense
anymore does that the time hey my eyes
are up here pal congratulations now
you're writing the emoji movie suffer
through a parade of dumb kids humor
bordering on anti comedy where the magic
is running to the ground so hard you
can't tell what happiness is anymore
I'm just beaming with pride I'm so
nervous I could almost shrug
stop don't overreact I told you not to
overreact please stop right now I'm
overwhelmed with passionate feelings for
you I get it ah but no where does this
comedy come closer to tragedy than Sir
Patrick Stewart playing a turd Oh proof
that you can give a man Talent Awards in
a knighthood but it's nothing compared
to the power of a paycheck you're so
soft Pope not too soft I hope so
experience the perfect film for our
times that doesn't teach you the
positive role of sadness like inside out
or turn a cash grab into something
insightful like the lego movie but
instead teaches children that life is a
meaningless mediocre joyless slob that
takes place mostly on your phone and
only exists to serve a global
conglomerates interest Oh
too honest again boob joke just during
my beer tube what what did I say
starring the following actual quotes
from the reviews of the emoji movie this
toxic piece of kitty trash isn't worth
of pixels here that it's the end of the
world
a viewer leaves the emoji movie a coder
person not only angries the film for
being unconscionably bad but resentful
of it for making them feel angry and the
poop jokes are minimal poop ah
a lot of good people probably had to
work really hard in this movie for a
really long time so I'm sorry not for
anything I said about the film just you
know those Lost years of your life I am
Optimus Prime and I want a reboot I have
to get off this planet winner winner
chicken dinner
I hear you can talk to fish but doctor I
am Pagliacci pickles pickles everywhere
booyah